sais tu les as c'est une barotte
[Musique]
votre famille vous
emmerde perdre mes soeurs
je le sens à l'intérieur du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bas est
allé en film
[Musique]
vivant
ce
[Applaudissements]
qui m'intéresse c'est votre histoire
tout le monde connaît mon histoire je
suis le survivant de bien sûr mais
personne ne nous a demandé comment vous
avez sur les deux
tu nous parles surtout pas lui moi
jamais
la fille que j'aimais au pays elle sait
pas que chiante frais placardé votre
histoire sur la côte est
parlez moi un peu du nazi qui deviennent
un peu comme un artiste de variété
est-ce que j'ai le choix on a toujours
le choix dans la vie
l'un n'a jamais entraîné
traître les hackers chinsky rien du tout
je suis désolé vérifie terrifié nourrir
car de partout je vous dis deurveilher
je vous jure que nous faisons tout pour
vous aider
aucune chance tout ce que tu peux faire
c'est sûr mais tu veux me tirer dessus
il faut que tu retires le cran de
sécurité chose que ferait un vrai
survivants demande le toit de tuer le
seul homme qui se dresse entre toi et la
chambre à gaz
c'était ça les choix qu'on devait faire
tous les jours
on n'avait encore jamais vu un d'aussi
près je suis désolé des choix faits
quand on se rappelle l'instant qu'un
journal eut une fille
ce cadavre est ce que tu as choisie
les pme sa
famille est ce que tu aimes le plus dans
ce monde elle vaut la peine de se battre
pour elle
elle m'a sauvé la vie